a brand new 25-year-old model is raking
in nearly
$111,000 per month for her modeling
agency in Barcelona which is somewhat
impressive but it's especially
impressive because this hot little
Spaniard is not a human she's a computer
model model created by AI to look
perfect and unlike most developments in
AI which I suspect will degrade us all
before wiping out human life entirely
Terminator style in the case of Iana
that's her name it's kind of clever
right if titillating jobs must exist I
am all for giving them to computers I'm
Michael no this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show jar jemy
is spilling the beans on what a top
Hollywood talent agent told all of us
years ago uh ahead of the lady balers
Premiere so we'll get to that in just
one second first though I don't want to
move off of this hot little Spanish
collection of zeros and ones too quickly
uh I guess this is my pro- aai week I'm
really into AI this week I'm not pro- AI
generally I'm Pro human being generally
but in the case of the story yesterday
where AI is writing stories for Sports
Illustrated I think that's F I think
probably AI writes better stories than
most journalists and probably AI is less
robotic than most liberal journalists
working today and I think it's good that
AI is now taking the job of models not
because I have anything against human
models I actually really care about
human models and because of that I want
them to lose their jobs to computers
because modeling generally is terrible
for
women there are some exceptions there
have been some people who have been
models and they've gotten out of it and
they've gone on to live good lives but
very often they end up being exploited
and degraded and treated as an object
and a commodity in themselves and it's
just not really good it's not good at
all and and so I think if you're going
to have a job where human beings are
treated as nothing but flesh for our own
titilation and entertainment then might
as well be a a computer doing it can't
really morally degrade a computer you
can do that to a human being the
criticism of the AI supermodels is that
it will create unfair standards for
other women this this is being reported
by Euro News some are worried the
unrealistic Perfection of these women
may make younger people obsessed with
wanting to be perfect that's a
ridiculous
criticism because we already have
Photoshop that's already true so human
women have their pictures taken and then
editors go in and they make them look
inhuman by taking away every little
wrinkle every little piece of fat
everything and so if younger women are
dealing with these body dysmorphia
issues uh that's already happening it's
just involving actual human beings on
the other side of the camera too uh in
this case I think it's absolutely great
I I've been thinking a lot about this
recently because I'm I'm returning to
the screen in this movie lady Ballers
and I'll tell you even the craft of
acting is giving me some pause now
because for my whole life I thought that
there was nothing immoral about acting I
thought it was just kind of strange that
for all of human history actors and
models were lumped in with criminals and
prostitutes as as far as the uh uh
social classes are concerned but but I'm
beginning to understand why which is
that when you are an actor you if you're
a good actor then you are not only
hitting your marks and saying your lines
but you are really
persuasively conveying the character
that you're supposed to play and the way
that we do that in Modern Life Is by
really truly believing the things that
an act that we are saying as actors that
we are believing the circumstances that
we find ourselves in as actors we are
furthermore Desiring the things that the
character desires and in so doing one
one warps one's own intellect one's own
desire one one's own will one's own soul
and I don't know that that's great so
I'm not here as the American Taliban
issuing a fatwa on all modeling and all
acting but contrary to what you're
hearing from everyone the lib actors
Screen Actors Guild and the
conservatives who fear transhumanism and
post the post-human
future I'm I'm not that upset with
computers replacing actors and models
it's probably best of all for the actors
and the models uh now speaking of fake
women new report just broke Dylan
malvaney has been named to the Forbes 30
under 30
list now the 30 under 30 list is a
little misleading is the list is
supposed to be the 30 most impressive
people under the age of 30 but it's not
really 30 people because they have all
sorts of different categories so it ends
up being a lot of people under 30 Dylan
Mulaney W for the category of
Creator or influencer I love that
category of Creator as though every no
one else on Earth creates it's just
people who talk on YouTube they're the
creators and everyone else they're just
automatons they're robots they're like
the AI of of that of that Spanish model
uh again maybe this is a contrary take
though this one is entirely
self-interested I am thrilled that Dylan
mulany has been named to the 30 under 30
the 30 under 30 is almost always
exclusively Libs and fashionable
politically correct sort of people and
movements and the fact that Dylan mulany
was named to the 30 under 30 I think
he's the cover of the magazine for the
premiere of our movie lady Ballers which
is a complete sendup of the movement uh
I think is just perfect I was at
Vanderbilt University last night and I
was giving a speech on settler
colonialism you can find that speech on
the YF YouTube channel and what do you
know I show up I start speaking and a
ton of these activists jump up and start
shrieking at me from the audience and I
said I was a little bit confused
actually because I didn't see any
protesters outside I guess it was chilly
they don't like physical uh discomfort
and then I I show up into the auditorium
I'm about to give my speech and they
start shrieking I said hold on wait what
are you protesting me for and they
started shrieking they're protesting me
because I
said which it obviously isn't and I said
okay well anyway here's here's my view
it happens to be correct and they were
shrieking and shrieking then finally the
cops escorted them out so there's a lot
of attention on this one very bizarre
issue and there will be more attention
when our movie premieres this Friday
only for daily wire members that is Lady
Ballers this Friday now when you want to
look good in a more edifying sustainable
and natural way you ought to check out
Jus cell right now go to jus.com I have
got a Christmas gift idea that is sure
to make you the hero of the Season we
all know that the holidays can be hectic
the shopping the cooking the never-
ending list of things to do but fear not
fear not
because I have discovered a gift that is
both thoughtful and transformative the
gift of genu cell skincare from now
until Christmas genu cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at Jus cell.com
KW treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness and sagging jawline
will disappear right before your eyes
with jus cell's most popular collection
genus cell promises immediate effects
you will see results in less than 12
hours guaranteed or your money back
you deserve to look and feel your best
this holiday season I love this company
you know the founder is a Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left Egypt for
the American dream it is uh really
really high-end ingredients in here much
better than you're going to see in other
products go to janus.com NES right now
get this incredible holiday discount
every order today is instantly upgraded
to free express shipping genucell.com
kwl today speaking of men and women love
and marriage and a baby carriage
a South Korean city is attempting to
reverse its birth rate
collapse with a novel policy that I
think we ought to replicate here and
that is to hold public Mass blind
dates to boost birth rates this is the
South Korean city of s snam they held a
mass blind dating event at a hotel on
Sunday for the express purpose of
getting young people to marry and then
have children because South Korea's
birth rates like so many birth rates
around the West are collapsing according
to one of the participating men we are
facing a real demographic crisis and the
government needs to do whatever it can I
don't understand people complaining over
this I I like the idea that this this
man participating you know one of the
blind daters just sits down and he says
hey
baby hey baby how do you like your wine
do you recognize that we have a
collapsing birth rate problem and the
government demands that we go back to my
place and have a fun night what that is
a really novel pickup line I never
considered that one back in my derel
days but that's a pretty good one uh
Soul a better known city in South Korea
almost had the exact same sort of event
they canceled it because there were
criticisms that this is a waste of money
I don't see how anyone could say this is
a waste of money it's a little weird
it's a little silly I'm I'm sure that
there will be some krogans out there who
who say that this is not a good use of
taxpayer
dollars this is the most important use
of taxpayer dollars of all the dumb
social programs out
there this is a program aimed at giving
your country the possibility to survive
I mean just literally to survive we
sometimes talk about how America's dying
our culture is dying we need to save
America why because there's one social
fat or another social fat or because
some left-wing hobby horse program got
cut in this case we are talking
literally about survival and death will
there be people in your country or not
and if there aren't people how are you
going to keep the economy afloat you're
going to open up the borders and you're
going to flood it with foreigners and
then you're going to lose your country
because a country is people a country is
not just an abstract idea floating in
outer space a country is not just the
geography and the purple mountains
Majesty it's the people and the
traditions and the Heritage and the the
lived experience of a Nation so of of
any program that you're going to spend
money on this is a great one I am all
for it and it's not just South Korea
doing it xiin ping over in China who I
know he's a communist dictator but as
I've pointed out recently that communist
dictator sometimes doesn't sound so
communist in fact he talks about the
importance of economic Li liberalization
in certain places to to boost the
economy he sounds like a national
conservative in some cases especially
here when xiin ping just recently said
quote it is necessary to guide women to
play their unique role in carrying
forward the traditional virtues of the
Chinese Nation and establishing good
family virtues to create a new trend of
family civilization only with harmonious
families good family education and
correct family traditions can children
be raised and Society develop in a
healthy
manner that is
so perfectly stated that is so obviously
correct that xiin ping is presenting
himself here as a as a more coherent
normal conservative figure than
basically anyone in the Republican party
in America what an indictment of the
Republican party in America that we need
to look for conservative wisdom to the
dictator of communist China but it's
true for goodness sakes think about xiin
Ping's visit to San Francisco for years
in this country we've been told there's
nothing we can do to clean up our cities
we just have to allow druggies to shoot
up on the street by the way you've heard
that even from some so-called
conservatives more libertarian minded
conservatives but they'll say the
government has no right to tell people
not to shoot up drugs if they want to do
it just don't me pay for it blah blah
blah whatever supposed right-wingers are
saying that but of course there's
nothing conservative about letting
addicts die of exposure there's nothing
conservative about finding feces on on
your sidewalks in your major cities it's
not conservative at all that's
licentious and radical and left-wing and
then you get the dictator of communist
China to show up and all of a sudden the
city looks like it's 1950 again goodness
sakes with Communists like this who
needs conservatives and with
conservatives is like this who needs
Communists not a bad idea to take note
from some of our allies South Korea and
adversaries China overseas both of whom
agree on a basic thing which is that we
need to have more babies and to have
more babies we need to have a basic
understanding of how biology Works how
babies are made our political Elite seem
to have missed that lesson in seventh
grade health class we further need to
know what marriage is and what family is
and in order to do that we need to
remember that men women are different
and they're not able to be substituted
one for the other men and women are
complimentary and need one another and
if we forget that fact then we're not
going to have any more kids we're not
certainly not going to have stable
families at least and if we don't have
that we're not going to have a country
for very
long the commies get it the the
normal kind of foreign conservatives get
it it's just the Americans on both sides
of the aisle though much more pronounced
on the left who don't seem to understand
this speaking of China here's some bad
stuff going on in
China They're bringing back the masks
and they're bringing back social
distancing this according to a report
from the Sun out of the UK China has
brought back masks social distancing in
a chilling echo of lockdown as they
battle a mystery pneumonia outbreak four
years on from covid alarming footage has
emerged of maske wearing crowds inside
Chinese hospitals as fears of a new
pandemic sweep across the globe okay
before I totally lose
it before I melt down in a Cascade of
fear and
trembling we can remember Asian people
have been wearing masks in public for a
very long
time Asian people have been wearing
masks on airplanes and even on public
streets for a long time that was always
an Asian thing and then during covid for
the first time it started to spill over
into the west and we mostly got rid of
it so the fact that some people people
in China are wearing masks doesn't worry
me all too much what worries me about
this story is the
number say four years on from covid four
years on from Co what happens every four
years what do you think might
explain the political reaction to covid
four years ago was it just that for the
first time ever everyone melted down out
of a panic over a cold we just happen to
really be afraid of that cold
over other
colds or do you think it might have had
that reaction might have had something
to do with the presidential election in
the prospect of another Donald Trump
term and do we think that maybe the
fearmongers now who don't seem to be
winning are freaking out over the
potential of another
virus because the exact same Prospect
faces them who was the biggest
beneficiary of
covid we could say the libs we could say
me mega Corporation was the biggest
transfer of wealth ever from the lower
classes to the upper classes in in all
of recorded
history I think the biggest beneficiary
of covid was China
China because Co shut down the United
States it politically neutered Donald
Trump after many other other attempts
that's the one that that
succeeded Trump was winning waging and
winning a trade war with China Co
stopped the trade war with
China Co got rid of Donald Trump because
it gave Democrats an excuse to change
all of the election rules to benefit
them
uh and what are we looking at now we're
looking at despite all of that Donald
Trump looking as though he can beat Joe
Biden Donald Trump up not just in
National polls which don't tell a lot of
the story but up in crucial states that
he's got to win if you look at the real
clear politics average of polls so we're
not talking about allers we're talking
about the most dependable source for
polling Trump is up almost five points
in Arizona Trump is up four or five
points in Georgia on Joe Biden Trump is
this is not a generic ballot this is not
fill in the blank who knows what's going
to happen Donald Trump is look according
to the polls and not just one or two all
of the polls and not just now for for a
very long time now Trump is looking like
he could win again so the libs are
freaking out they're going to try to
pull some virus out from under the rug
they're going to try to find some excuse
to to cement their cheating in in the
new voting rules but it's looking pretty
strong so as a result of that some
people who hate Trump especially but
even people who like Trump are trying to
find a different nominee one potential
new nominee would be Nikki
Haley uh the Koch back you know the Koch
brothers now coch brother I guess the
coke Network backed Americans for
Prosperity has just endorsed Nikki
Haley AFP action they say is proud to
throw our full support behind Nikki
Haley who offers America the opportunity
to turn the page on the current
political era to win the Republican
primary and defeat Joe Biden next
November this is being reported as a
really tough blow to Ronda santis and I
see why it's being reported that way
because Americans for Prosperity they
don't like Trump they're going to pick
someone to back who's going to be the
anti-trump candidate for most of this
race DeSantis was viewed as the most
viable anti-trump candidate the fact
that they're backing Nikki Haley is a is
a tough blow now some of us might have
seen this coming hate to say I told you
so and the reason being that Ronda
santis looks really really strong
because he seems to have many of the
great qualities of Donald Trump while
also having many of the great qualities
that appeal to the less conservative
more moderate slightly more squishy
voters more establish lishment voters so
you look at Ronda Santos and you say
he's smart he's principled he's
conservative he's effective he's done a
great job in Florida he's popular he
gets reelected he oh man this guy's
perfect sure
except that also might make him the
weakest candidate because the Trump
people aren't going to go for him
because they already have their guy in
the race Trump and the non-trump people
aren't going to go for him because he's
too trumpy so in a way though on one
side he looks like the strongest
candidate in another sense from another
Vantage he is the weakest candidate in
the race he's a man without a
home but the reason that I actually
don't believe that this is a tough blow
to Ronda santis is I don't think this is
going to matter at all you know I like
Nikki haly very much personally and so
I'm happy for her that she got a big
endorsement and it'll give her a lot of
money and and some staff but I don't
think it's going to matter and the
reason I think it's not going to matter
is because of this graph also from Real
Clear Politics also the average of all
the polls this is the max view of the
graph going back to the very start of
this primary and people are always
talking about DeSantis surging DeSantis
falling Haley surging this person
that nothing has changed if you look
beyond the headlines that are just
trying to get you
clicks if anything has changed at
all Haley is gone up a tiny little bit
DeSantis has gone down a little bit
Trump has gone up a little
bit but it's basically exactly the same
nothing in this whole race the different
candidates the debates the spending the
ads the stunts the nothing has affected
anything at all so now the Cook network
is going to pour a lot of money into
Nikki
Haley if I were a Gambling Man look the
cokes have made a lot more money than I
have but if I were a Gambling Man I
would not put money on anything in this
race
changing now when you want to change
your dogs when nutrition you got to
check out Ruff greens right now go to
Ruff greens.com the holidays are here
while you're out shopping for your
family and friends do not forget to shop
for your pets too give your dog the gift
of a healthier and happier life with
Ruff greens
naturopathic doctor Dennis black the
founder of Ruff greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food might as well be
considered dead food since it contains
very little nutritional value let rough
greens bring your excuse me rough greens
bring your dogs food to life rough
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and don't forget antioxidants that your
dog needs you don't even have to go out
and get new dog food you just sprinkle
rough Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving raving
about rough greens it supports healthy
joints improves bad breath boosts energy
levels and much more you are what you
eat right now natural AIC Dr Dennis
black is so confident that this will
improve your dog's health he's offering
a free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it delivered straight to your
door in just a few days go to Ruff
greens.com Michel Mi i h a l or call 844
ruff1 123 that is rfffg greens.com m i c
h a l or call 844 Ruff Ru ff1 123 today
do you remember those hon days when we
were allowed to laugh at things that
were absurd instead of having to say
that they AR aren't absurd that they are
in fact very very good and that you're a
bad person if you even suggest otherwise
back when Hollywood could make comedy
films like dodgeball Wedding Crashers
Tropic Thunder without having to tow
some politically correct line well the
daily wire is not tired of laughing and
this Friday we are dropping the most
triggering movie of the decade so far
it's a sports comedy about the funniest
thing to ever happen in sports grown men
who cannot beat other grown men calling
themselves women and then absolutely
dominating girls who spent their entire
lives training to be the best every
studio in Hollywood should be racing to
make this movie but they aren't and they
won't and they can't their worldview
simply will not allow them to say what
virtually every American knows to be
true that the entire reason that we
created women's sports was to keep the
men out that men cannot become women no
matter what some clown with a PhD and
gender studies says on the subject you
are allowed to believe those things you
are allowed to laugh at people who do
not now you can here is a look at the
official trailer for lady
ballers in a world where women's
sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
[Music]
[Applause]
Year guys this is serious sports can be
your Pathway to a better life what like
yours please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient in becoming a winner
maybe you should try it
sometime are you going to move I am
not let's cut to the chase I know you're
not a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you can beat them what do
you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day join this
is the way the world is now my
8-year-old daughter told me all about it
so a guy can become a girl with no
physical changes at all oh that's called
ginger fluid so I can be a woman on the
court and a man in the bedroom I can't
believe it nice you mean when you're
sleeping yes Coach Alex we could play
basketball we have to get the whole team
back together it's time we're in I'm in
I'm in to play Lady balers m
H like a girl gu what I'm with
her is my trth this is my
trth from Heroes day one of being a girl
athlete I love being a girl to sheo we
could dominate every woman's sport
running swimming soccer I said sport
Felix is basketball Boys Nobody
watches excuse me are these seats
open never mind getting
dunks and tuing
[Music]
Trunks you know she
didn't that's the biggest I've ever seen
on lady I don't care lady
Ballers one can even be trans aged now
which provides shelix with a wonderful
opportunity to relive all the
experiences that she missed out on in
school streaming exclusively on daily
wire plus December
[Music]
1st now here's the catch you can only
watch lady Ballers with a daily wire
Plus Membership do you not have a daily
wire Plus subscription yet what's wrong
with you join the dailywire plus team
get
5050 off your new membership right now
go to dailywire.com subscribe sign up
for exclusive access do not miss the
lady Boulders live Premier event on
dailywire plus Friday night 8:00 pm
Eastern what a great date night all
right turning our attention back to
politics and politicians the house
Democrats and actually drag queens oddly
enough so I guess there's a tie-in
Democrats are moving to expel the
embattled and eccentric Republican
Congressman George Santos George Santos
has been under Fire because he appears
to have lied about everything in his
past and defrauded a lot of people and
there was a house ethics investigation
and it's not looking good for the guy
and
uh well anyway here's their argument Mr
Speaker pursuant to Clause 2a1 of rule 9
resolution I Rise to give notice of my
intent to raise a question of the
Privileges of the house the form of the
resolution is as follows house
resolution
114 resolved that pursuant to Article 1
Section 5 Clause 2 of The Constitution
of the United States Representative
George Santos be and he hereby is
expelled from the House of
Representatives thank you Mr Speaker we
have to expel him and why do we have to
expel
George Santos from our nation's highest
legislative body well he lied apparently
about his ethnic background he used a
funny phrase a phrase that I used too he
said he was Jewish but there doesn't
seem to be evidence that he's Jewish or
so
okay has any other member of the lower
or upper chamber of the United States
Congress ever done such a thing would
you was that does that ring a bell at
all would someone who was one
1,28
Native American would would anyone like
that ever remain a sitting United States
Senator oh right yeah the Dems do that
well you see uh George Santos he took
money
inappropriately oh yeah do you think any
Democrat would ever do that let's check
Nancy Pelosi's portfolio how's that
looking that's she made a lot of money
for being in government her whole life
let's go further let's check Bob
menendez's portfolio Bob Menendez New
Jersey Democrat Senator he's still there
right why wait hold on
but we got to kick out George Santos
that seems a little strange the problem
with criticizing George Santos is not
that he's innocent he's not it's not
that he didn't commit serious crimes he
did I mean he he appears to have
committed fraud I consider I and Dante
the Divine poet consider fraud to be
basically the worst sin you can possibly
commit defrauding uh betraying one's
benefactors is the sort of thing that in
Dante's Divine Comedy gets you put into
the mouth of Satan in the river Co cus
being gnawed by the the chief of the
Devils for all of all of eternity so
yeah it's that's
bad the problem is that the Democrats do
all the same
stuff so I'm I'm not saying I would
endorse the guy to run again I'm not
saying I'm going to send him a campaign
donation certainly not I don't want my
identity stolen
but why would I call on him to resign
when the Democrats get away with all the
same stuff with impunity at a much
higher level for a much longer time the
only reason that the libs are going
after DeSantis
DeSantis dantos not DeSantis he's a good
guy the reason they're going after
Santos is
because we have a very slim Republican
majority in the house and they think if
they can Whittle away at that then it's
going to be easier to stop the
Republicans from obstructing Biden's
agenda that's all it's about and so for
that reason it's going to come up for a
vote maybe up for a vote already
today and I think it would be crazy for
Republicans to vote to expel him I agree
that he deserves to be expelled I'm not
in any way defending
Santos for the crimes that he would seem
quite obviously to have
committed but they're not throwing him
out of Congress for the crimes he's
committed they're throwing him out of
Congress in a really cynical political
Ploy and they're not throwing out their
own members who have done similar things
so no I think every Republican should
vote to keep Santos in office the reason
in particular is that he says he won't
run for office again so this is merely
about this Congress it's a two-year term
it's not going to be going on for much
longer he'll be out of office soon
enough maybe then a republican will have
a chance to mount a strong campaign but
if you kick out Santos now if the
Democrats do muster enough Republicans
to have a two-third vote to expel then
there's going to be a special election
in New York and some Dem is going to
replace him most likely why would we do
that why why do Republicans always
willingly just hand over power to
Democrats on some M mistaken
understanding of principle that is
really no principle at all now speaking
of crossdressers I should I should
mention for those who are unaware George
Santos apparently is a crossdresser that
there was another which again I just I
find him so funny and charming and a
meme that I I'm not going to really
attack him I'll attack him for the fraud
I guess but for these kinds of things I
find that eccentric and weird and kind
of fun funny but uh not a sufficient
reason to kick a guy out of Congress
especially when the Democrats are trying
to but but speaking of crossdressers
Jeremy just showed up on the uh pbd
podcast uh to describe an episode that I
remember I was here for this episode
years ago we were talking to a top agent
at UTA and we were we at the daily wire
were maybe going to do some work with
UTA the agency and they said there's
just one thing that we're not allowed to
do if we really want to make it in high
levels of media and and show business
and here's what they said we can't do
that movie ain't going to no
theaters unless just you you warn
everybody one of the one of the top
agents at UTA came to us years ago not
that many years ago a couple of years
ago and said hey we'd love to work with
you guys we can do some huge things
together and I said you there's no way
you'll ever do huge things with us we
believe this we believe that he said
yeah yeah yeah we don't care about any
of that we just care about you know
there's an opportunity here we want to
take it he said the only thing is you
got to back off this issue so I don't
care what you say about abortion don't
care what you say about religion don't
care what you say about who to vote for
don't care what you say about taxes got
to back off this issue this is the
religious issue of our time for the left
this represents the culmination of their
religious beliefs uh and so when we went
to theatrical Distributors there it was
a we not even going to engage in the
conversation it's not that they passed
it was just like here's a great example
the Hollywood trades have covered every
movie we've made at Daily wire so far
they won't even write about this one and
and I understand because that would be
putting themselves on the other side of
the actual religion that matters within
their
industry he's totally right he's totally
right this is the religious issue and it
it's religious in the sense that when
you actually get down to it is not about
the science and it's not about it's not
even even just about the decadent sexual
desires of of depraved
leftists it's about a a religious
question is the human nature best
explained
by traditional religion the the
Christian view that we're Body and Soul
United here hylomorphic beings or is
human nature best described by Gnostic
dualism best described by the notion
that the physical world and the
metaphysical world are not joined
together but they're actually in
opposition that the physical world is
evil and the metaphysical world is the
secret
truth it's an ancient heresy it's
cropped up a number of times in history
and it's cropped up again so it is a
Jeremy's actually being precise in his
language here it is a religious
issue the only thing that's frustrating
here is it's it's not the only religious
issue for the
left well there's a lot that's
frustrating about a top agent telling us
that but part of it is that it's it's
not the only religious issue that top
agent a nice
guy he didn't
realize that right now the one issue
you're not allowed to talk about
is but two years from now it'll be some
other
issue and 10 years ago it was some other
issue and it's always
changing so they think they're being
really magnanimous they say look you can
talk about whatever you want you can
believe what ever you want we're so
liberal we're so open-minded there's
just this one
thing and the one thing is always the
crucial issue that matters the the one
thing is always the issue that is really
hot that could go maybe one way or the
other where public opinion actually
matters where there could be serious
political consequences we're allowed to
talk about so-called gay marriage now
you know why because it's a dead issue
at the moment because the Supreme Court
invented some new definition of marriage
because the Romantic poet Anthony
Kennedy on the Supreme Court found an
invisible Inc in the Constitution a
special constitutional right to intimacy
or
whatever and at the at the time when
there was something even vaguely
resembling a debate over the nature of
marriage you weren't really allowed to
talk about that you'd lose your job
remember they ran Brandon Ike out of out
of Mozilla out of Firefox the creator of
Firefox because he had donated a very
small amount of money to a ballot
proposition that was going to define
marriage as what it had always been
namely a union between a man and a woman
a ballot proposition in Liberal C
California that passed even the liberal
Californians said yeah we know what
marriages and because the leftist
vindictive operators found out that this
somewhat prominent guy in business had
donated I don't know like five cents to
the proposition they destroyed his
career you at that time you were not
allowed to talk about that was the one
issue but then they won on that issue
and it doesn't look like the fake
definition of marriage is particularly
endangered at the moment so okay you'll
talk you can talk about that go play in
your sandbox conservatives talk about
anything that doesn't
matter but don't talk
about is right right and here's their
argument they'll say because right now
there's a real threat
to about about whether they have access
to life
saving and when they say those sorts of
things they're admitting to you the
strategy they're saying yeah you're not
allowed to talk about anything that
matters you can talk about things that
don't matter but you can't talk about
anything that matters that's where we
draw the line oh okay so you're saying
we can never have any influence in the
Public
Square okay yeah no thanks no thanks
we're not we're going to go do our own
thing until you stomp that out too but
for now you haven't been able to stomp
us out yet so we're going to go make our
Our Lady balers movie and I bet a lot of
people are going to watch it speaking of
liberal hegemony Karen jeanpierre
spokesman for the president the putative
president was just asked to explain why
the economy is so bad
all this time into the Biden
Administration and she gave a felet
answer why do you think it is that when
you say the economy is improving and
President Biden says the economy is
improving that a majority of Americans
outside of this building are not buying
it so here's the
thing when we walked into this
Administration the economy was on a tail
a tail spin that is the fact because of
the last administration because of the
Trump administration because of how they
dealt with uh with dealt with covid and
the pandemic because they didn't have a
comprehensive plan the president came in
he passed the American Rescue plan which
was able to get the economy back on its
feet which is able to open up small
business small business were able to
open up schools were able to open up and
we understand what Americans have been
feeling over the last 2 three years it's
going to take some time we get that it's
going to take some time but it does not
take away how we have seen the economy
getting back on it feet we actually had
to fix the problem that we saw that the
last Administration left us this is even
worse than the usual just blame the last
guy routine that the Democrats in
particular
use oh yes years into the Biden
Administration the reason for all of his
problems is
Trump this is even worse
because Karen jeanpierre is blaming
Trump for Los certain battles to
Democrats like Joe
Biden she's saying look Donald Trump he
shut down those businesses he he shut
down the economy over covid yeah because
you made him you forced his hand Trump
wanted to reopen the economy relatively
quickly wanted to reopen by Easter you
guys wouldn't let him he got he got
outplayed by you finally one time Trump
was able to evade your WS like like Road
Runner running away from Wy coyote he
was able to evade it and all these
different unprecedent Ed ways but you
did you got him on Co and he shut the
economy down and and now you're blaming
him for it this is like the teacher
Union president Randy wein Garten saying
that she tried to reopen the schools but
but she wasn't able to Randy wi Garten
single-handedly kept the schools closed
almost
single-handedly and then they just turn
around they ju this is this is so much
worse than just stretching the truth a
little bit or blaming the last guy off
offhandedly Karen jeanpierre is saying
the exact opposite of reality a total
inversion a total lie do you think
people are going to buy that though I
don't think so I think people are going
to think back and say you know
Trump had a great economy
Trump under Trump everything was going
great and then Biden came in and
everything's not going great and now Joe
Biden's approval rating is the worst
ever you know Jimmy
Carter whatever you think of the guy's
politics obviously wasn't a very
successful president he is a very
impressive guy who at 99 years old
showed up to his wife's funeral he's
been in hospice for over nine months now
and the guy he's just a very impressive
guy and one of the kind of jokes about
this is well a consolation for Jimmy
Carter enduring all these Health
ailments and and living so long is he
gets to see a guy who's a worse
president than him and that would be Joe
Biden that can help man sleep well at
night when you want to sleep well at
night you got to check out beam right
now go to shop
beam.com the holidays are here the last
thing that you need during this busy
time of year is to miss out on a great
night's sleep that is why our team loves
beam's dream powder beam's dream powder
contains a powerful all natural blend of
ingredients including magnesium L
theanine it is not just your
run-of-the-mill sleep aid it is a
concoction carefully crafted to help you
slip into the sweet Embrace of rest
without the grogginess that often
accompanies other sleep remedies sleep
is the foundation of our mental and
physical health you must have a
consistent nighttime routine to function
at your best today our listeners get a
special discount on beam's dream powder
they're bestselling hot cocoa for sleep
with no added sugar now available in
delicious flavors like cinnamon cocoa
chocolate peanut butter and mint chip
better sleep has never tasted better
just mix beam dream into hot water or
milk stir or froth and enjoy before
bedtime ooh sounds cozy if you find
yourself battling the Bedtime Blues give
it a shot your weary self will thank you
try beam's bestselling dream powder take
advantage of their biggest sale of the
Year get up to 5050 5% off for a limited
time when you go to shop
beam.com discount is auto applied to
checkout no code necessary that is shop
beam.com NES kwes for 50% off my
favorite comment yesterday is from
Cheyenne the wolf who says if I wasn't
already a member I would surely sign up
for this Friday yeah of course this is
the thing to see I was thinking about
that myself if I were not a member of
the daily wire Ben finally gave me a
login Shapiro not Davies
I I would sign up for this would be the
thing that would get me to to sign up I
might have signed up for what as a
woman I'm I get you know actually the
thing that would have gotten me to sign
up is if I were able to get Early Access
or or discounts or something to the
beautiful Mayflower cigars 21 plus to
order some exclusions Supply but beyond
that I think this would be the this
would be the the piece of content lady
Ballers would be the one to get me to
sign up now speaking of the
economy Zoom fatigue is taking its toll
on your health this is according to a
report published in the journal
scientific
reports looked for physiological signs
of fatigue in 35 students attending
lectures on engineering at an Austrian
University uh they found that there were
notable differences between the imperson
and the online groups so since covid a
lot of people have had to and even
chosen to do their meetings and even
have social Gatherings on
zoom and the survey the study found that
video participants fatigue mounted over
the course of the session their brain
states showed that they were struggling
to pay attention the group's moods
varied as well in-person participants
reported feeling livelier happier and
more active online participants said
they felt tired drowsy and fed up of
course I hate Zoom sometimes people want
to schedule Zoom meetings with me I try
to avoid it I'll I'll have it on the
phone if I'm going to do an in not
inperson meeting but I want to do stuff
in person and the reason is it doesn't
take a scientific study to know that
human beings prefer to do things in
person than virtually and the reason for
this is that same religious error that
Jeremy was pointing out that we were
discussing earlier namely we are
incarnate beings we are Body and Soul we
are not to be abstracted one from the
other we're both tied together this is I
think one of the drivers of
the beyond the uh bizarre philosophy The
Logical conclusion of liberalism beyond
the I don't know whatever chemicals
they're putting in the water a a Big
Driver of it is technology the fact that
we live in the virtual world so often
now makes us think that our bodies don't
really matter that we are something
totally different from our bodies and if
you really believe that then you can say
all right well I don't like my body I I
I feel alienated from my body so I'm
going to pretend that my identity is
nothing to do with my body and I might
even chop my body up to to make it look
a little bit more like my fantasy view
of of who I supposedly really am but at
a at a more quotidian level this is
happening to people all the time as they
undertake their stupid Zoom
meetings you're that's not going to to
satisfy you to just sit in front of a
screen all day and look at little moving
pixels you're a human being you're
supposed to move around and talk to real
human beings and touch them and even
during goodness gracious during covid
when we we weren't allowed to see our
loved ones you had to hug people up
against a plate of glass or something no
we need to hug each other we need to we
need
to have human contact we're a coupling
creature a social animal the political
animal
okay the liberal culture wants to
replace marriage with well a new fake
definition of marriage and ultimately
just replace it with porn you know just
replace it with with uh uh sitting alone
in in your in your home looking at
pixels wants to replace office settings
work settings where you see people and
interact and have lunch wants to replace
that
with sitting in your home looking at
moving pixels it wants to replace
everything with this abstracted you
wants to replace your community of
friends with virtual ual online friends
all the rest of it it's not going to
work that will never work we are
incarnate
beings now speaking of bodily reality
there's a good story today this is from
Indiana a baby a newborn baby was
surrendered to and safely retrieved from
a baby box in Indiana have you I've
covered baby boxes on this show before
baby boxes are this kind of silly but
really important
innovation in public policy which is for
people who have a baby but don't want
the baby instead of leaving it outside
at a fire department where it could dive
exposure instead of throwing it in a
trash can which happens instead of
killing the baby you just surrender the
baby to a nice warm climate controlled
box where the baby will then be accepted
anonymously and then uh given to an
adoptive couple that that actually wants
to take care of the baby and so far this
year uh seven babies have been
surrendered in Indiana alone in in these
baby boxes 16 across the country and
this is a very new policy it's not in a
lot of places I I met the guy actually
who pioneered this idea uh the the baby
will likely be adopted by a family
within 30 to 45 days this is really
beautiful stuff you know there there are
seven babies in the state of Indiana
seven human beings who will look back
one day and say wow that policy is
responsible for me being alive most
likely wow that's a reminder
that polit that the law is a teacher
that
politics can can shape human behavior of
course that laws will of course shape
human behavior and they have very very
practical tangible effects it's not just
you know the economic forecasts 30 years
into the future it's hey is that human
being going to be alive or is that human
being going to be killed as a baby what
what's it going to be we're incarnate
creatures it's it's a reminder how many
people commit more horrible crimes
because of
Shame think about that this this woman
who surrendered her baby didn't want to
keep the baby might have felt some shame
that she got knocked up in in other
circumstances if that baby box were out
there she might have she might have
killed the baby disposed of the baby to
to which is a far more heinous crime
than you know sleeping out of WD blck or
something but a lot of people do that
and so we in our public policy we need
to account for that and we can pass laws
to change Behavior change the view of uh
the the value of human life they can do
it in Soul they can do it in China we we
ought to do it here too the rest of the
show continues now you do not want to
miss it become a member use code NES
canw has check out for two months free
on all annual
plans
[Music]
a